let's try your voice now my name is
Katniss Everdeen I'm from district 12
unnecessary over-the-top exposition a
lot also couldn't they start her out on
something a little simpler she can't
talk we're gonna test his response and
somebody remembers from home someone
that will be a surprise to you and the
audience wait Katniss doesn't have to
wear a jumpsuit but prim who moments
earlier didn't have to wear jumpsuit is
now wearing a jumpsuit did they were all
out new outfits between the day that
happened between the last film in this
film good thing Pete is wearing the
standard-issue modesty leggings provided
by this underground hospital now has to
pay for what he's done her damaged vocal
cords speaking boys sounds just like my
morning after a really good night voice
this will they won't they with these two
just needs to be a won't they because
they clearly don't want to dedicate any
time to having Katniss's emotions toward
Gail make any sense it's like kissing
someone a Strunk doesn't count this
micro PSA is brought to you by the Cosby
consortium that's an application of the
hummingbird trap this is why why is so
popular because it lets teens fantasize
that adults give a shit about their
dumbass ideas I guess there are no rules
anymore about what a person can do to
another person the society killed
children for sport there were never any
rules this is the nut on the hologram
the make your movie look futuristic and
stupid at the same time CGI crutch that
despite years and years of progress
never improves they took heavy losses
Wendell and Christy's acting specialty
is showing up as a military commander
for all of four minutes in blockbuster
films your people have suffered more
than just about anyone elses the hats
the gap which is why I won't condone a
mess suicide also because they already
did that at the dam in district 5 the
civilians in that in the underground
impossible to penetrate military
compound what the hell for does the
movie not really want to show us this
Avalanche plan they just cooked up how's
it the series made enough money to show
it bad probably not we just want to stay
here with Katniss while she looks extra
concerned that's why he killed Kaito and
he killed trash - killed cop I can't
even remember who any of these people
are anymore it's maybe more of a sin on
me but I don't have a sin counter so
Senna made her a suit bulletproof which
is great what's even better is that this
wasn't a headshot I said it before but
I'm gonna say it again these displays
are the fucking worst they're the
quality of an old CRT television
complete with analog tape tracking but
they are also slightly transparent which
is a terrible idea if you want to watch
what is on the screen and not what is
behind it he toasted a glorious era
coming to its bitter end
Snow's poisoning game is so impeccably
timed Antonius was able to hear all of
snow speech just
for dyeing also the Capitol embraces the
names murdering tactics and general
decadence of the Roman Empire but they
are surprisingly short on orgies send us
out that of course it cost him with
people improve I would sure hope so this
movie seems to imply that not everyone
is wearing bulletproof clothing which
would be cleaned up
given that they're always going into
active war zones the whole tacky romance
drama and the defender of the hopeless
act even though it's not an act which
makes it even more unbearable this
basically sums up why I don't like any
of these movies well I know is it I
would have saved myself a lot of
suffering if I just given that bread to
the pig I know he's supposed to be all
brainwashed against Katniss but he's not
wrong as far as the soldiers know you
survived a bullet to the heart because
all the soldiers are idiots can't assume
that giant rigid plate she was wearing
on her chest was bullet proof wedding
between two people I don't care about
it's about power for the course when it
comes to all the weddings I witness also
this movie is two hours and 15 minutes
long and it has time for this bullshit
everyone still has to wear janitor
jumpsuits except for Evie who gets to
wear her Lady Gaga outfits again and
even though this takes place in an
entirely different universe than ours
the people of Panem still have to deal
with folksy rustic chic weddings I guess
I could just stay here and cover for you
only a few minutes earlier she was
lamenting about how much she didn't like
Katniss right now she's willing to
assist her with her half-baked plan to
kill President Snow of all the things to
survive whatever apocalypse resulted in
Panem I can't believe middle music was
one of them three-sixty hug am I
supposed to believe that Katniss was
able to sneak into this giant armory
from the living quarters and hop onto a
cargo plane all while being Katniss one
of the most recognizable people in all
of Panem I guess so just so future
dystopian dictators are aware it's
probably a good idea to build at least
one other city to rule from it's really
hard to flee the capital when there's
literally nowhere else to go around it
is about three steps away from the
fashion of Bill and Ted's reality so I
figure the Hunger Games have to happen
before people start being excellent to
one another President Snow was building
a minefield of traps the next thing she
says isn't we have a giant map of it so
it will be very easy to avoid these
traps no need to go off on him Katniss
is planning on going off on her own then
why would she let everyone know she was
in the Capitol by walking out of the
cargo vessel in plain sight
now all the rebels in the Capitol will
know she's missing when she goes off on
her own which may end up not being a
problem because she went missing in 13
and no one seemed to give us each one of
you as a lead some form of combat except
for the two cameramen in the director
barrel eating pizzazz because we don't
want the game makers to know we have
this Intel has a self-destruct on it
yeah but doesn't the fact that if you
survive even a couple of those booby
traps tell them that ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the 76th Hunger
Games
if only do you know why you originally
wanted to see The Hunger Games it was
because of the fucking Hunger Games yeah
it was brutal and terrible but it was a
hell of a lot more fun than this
revolution bull would you have paid to
see either of these two Mockingjay
movies if it weren't for the first 200
games probably not
didn't they blow up this dam in the last
movie I guess it's a different dance
since I have no idea where the other dam
was or why it was important I reserve
the right to claim the filmmakers didn't
need it what's that manufactured by
Tiger Electronics just on a frame the
cast of Maze Runner Scorch Trials is
avoiding wicked hold it Pollux tighter
they're gonna film them shooting at the
pods and use the footage for more
propose how is that not going to
giveaway that they all know where the
pods are look I get why the game makers
made all these booby traps for the
rebels to run through and everything but
I don't know why they made this obstacle
course so sporting this is war you can
make it super unfair if you want to now
the rebels even got this far as amazing
oh no an exploding car that makes
absolutely no impact to the scene
whatsoever and wants to add them to the
proper sure that he's on our side now
the rebel brass seem to care way more
about making videos than formulating
battle tactics friend lover victor
fiance the cook the thief his wife her
lover he will be a vital part of the
democracy that follows our victory be a
vital part of the democracy that follows
our later you got it the guy recited
each line one at a time after the line
was fed to it he is yet to say it all
together he does not got it this is
stupid I mean yeah I would kill you
alright but what about slamming a big
metal gate down so they can't go any
farther or bombs for the dogs with bees
in their mouths that chippies at you
hell there's a possibility to the rebels
we're going to trigger this booby trap
might also booby trap the place where
they were taking cover right now I mean
Jesus also this hunger games is like the
first scene in Raiders of the Lost Ark
except it's basically the whole movie
even after constant warnings about how
there might be pods we don't know about
Bogg still decides to trust his little
gizmo without any hesitation just don't
trust the guy who's dying still has the
moxie to play the pronoun game there is
this tar coming from good of that
overflowing river of oil to stop blowing
right at this very spot so that Peter
can attack Katniss and neither of them
dies I think we're leaving teen
dystopian future movie and heading
towards a softcore Saw movie under game
series having already copied 2012 last
time copies the day after tomorrow
the finale I guess it would have been
unreasonable for the black sludge to
continue rising so they drew the line at
convenience how did all that overflowing
oil retreat back to where it came from
do they have some sort of vacuum or
something to bring all that oil back
seems like it would be in the capital's
best interest just to leave the ocean of
oil there strand these people and starve
them to death it looks like they decided
to hide out in the bottle from I Dream
of Jeannie I guess every structure the
capital is built is extremely brittle
and could be destroyed with a relatively
small amount of explosives the future
depicted in this series is violent and
bleak but at least everyone gets really
good reception even in the middle of
battles Katniss Everdeen seems to have
met a violent end
the rebels didn't really hide when they
ran across the courtyard and they could
definitely be seen in that footage the
Capitol just broadcast yet the
peacekeepers only shot where the bullets
were coming from and nothing else
the Capitol really needs to work on
getting their cameras to work all the
time instead of just when it's
convenient to our main characters these
four were Capitol citizens and therefore
exempt from The Hunger Games
so why did they have these glamour shots
on file also this isn't an actual Hunger
Games where they should honor the fallen
and Caesar just talked about how they
were foolish so why the fuck is a
Capitol even wasting their time with
this in memoriam reel so Katniss
Everdeen a poor unstable girl with
nothing but a small talent with a bow
and arrow is dead earlier in the movie
President Snow's edition you have a
habit of burying people before they're
dead but here he is doing the exact same
thing didn't see a body of any kind but
declares Katniss dead and it's not even
a propaganda film he really thinks she's
dead
those of you who don't know me please
allow me to introduce myself
the Capitol with all its vast resources
can't seem to figure out a way to keep
the rebels from hijacking broadcast I
had no idea I meant so much to her
she's been a propaganda pond since the
first Hunger Games and it's not like we
don't know at this point the coin is
shady the quasi snarky attitude she's
copping here really comes off that's
naive my brother knows these tunnels
really well of course he does and when
they arrive at the hedge maze that I'm
sure this movie has there will be a guy
who built the maze in their small
propaganda party also the Capitol booby
trap everywhere above-ground but never
once thought the underground tunnels
would be a place where a rebel force
might try to enter man these subway
tunnels are super well lit for places
where people shouldn't be walking around
in the first place but the Capitals
electricity bills are insane if
dictators have one strength it's keeping
the trains running during a revolution
we're too exposed here
yeah but no booby traps so it's better
than above ground right they survived I
don't know how I do they walked up one
flight of stairs and didn't get shot at
pretty simple to me I didn't stop here
for a bit and get some
yeah we're gonna have to watch all of
that also he would show me pictures my
life but some weren't real it would have
been nice for them to actually show this
instead of having Peeta tell the whole
story just another way these last two
movies wasted their time did someone
spill some a medieval horror in this
Hunger Games you gotta go we gotta get
out of here now after PETA's urgency we
spend roughly four minutes just slowly
walking around the sewers getting me
enough time for the suspense to wear off
and the frustration over nothing
happening - we're on here's two minutes
of our heroes crawling around in the
sewer
because Mockingjay makes more money and
less sense if it's two separate movies
Oh No Judds also somehow these vicious
creatures ran through all this water
without making a noise until someone
turned around and noticed them since we
aren't some kind of jungle like the
earlier Hunger Games we get weird alien
creatures rather than mutant monkeys
also did one of these alien clones
whisper Katniss how minute ago are these
things senti it enough to emulate movie
tropes I guess in this universe if you
already have a giant bruise on your
abdomen from a bullet wound you can't
get anymore otherwise this would hurt
like and Katniss would be down for the
count
yet here we are close-up dark quick
edited random nothingness of an action
scene this movie steals from the house
of aliens but instead of stealing the
million dollars in gold bullion on the
coffee table
they stole a watch in an umbrella and
call it a day that's what you get when
you decide to get married I waited on
this in long enough
how does cata still have our arrows to
shoot she had like 12 to start right and
only four of them were the exploding
ones either the movie is fucking with us
or she has a Mary Poppins quiver
President Snow discovered Adam Sandler's
pixels technology doesn't snow and his
minions clearly did not give up because
their pawns are destroying everything
these assholes jump at the last minute
how did they have any idea that whatever
it is behind them was going to stop at
that exact spot and why would you make a
booby trap that arbitrarily cuts itself
off halfway through the subway station I
don't remember falling asleep but did
not just wake up watching a live-action
adaptation of Kung Fu Panda I know you
you're a stylist in the games until snow
decided I wasn't pretty enough anymore
in snows defense lady you took the name
tigress way to literally hide down here
in mee maws basement also nearly this
whole movie is running from one place to
another and then waiting for 10 minutes
and no one even has an interesting sex
story to tell I'd even accept a straight
theft of one of the soldiers stories and
Saving Private Ryan right now no sin
just sweet relief a Bronco
signal can be picked up in this basement
even if I didn't know what was gonna
happen at the end of this scene I'd be
an asshole walking in this crown
thinking snow was gonna pack all of us
into his mansion and then I'd leave
because what a bunch of bullshit rebel
missile ex machina Katniss and Gale
somehow avoid getting hit by a hail of
gunfire
then this explosion makes them fall
sideways so they can avoid getting hit
by the truck now that is some lucky bolt
right there I mean come on no debris
whatsoever from that blast hits Katniss
the big twist at the end is not that
Katniss is an indestructible robot
because she would have to be to survive
all this movie is throwing at her prim
sits there staring at Katniss so long
you might as well plaster a neon sign on
the screen that says Prinze gonna die at
the last two movies runtime is dedicated
to Katniss in hospitals fight was over
after then Capitol drop those bombs to
defend the powers so we spend the entire
series building up two or more and then
we don't even get to see how that war
ends peacekeepers palace guards they had
kids in there too once again cat
assembly the audience are being told
what happened after the fact this is the
most boring episode of MTV Cribs I've
ever seen let her in good thing an
authority figure was here at this very
moment so Katniss could confront snow I
must concede it was a masterful move on
Gwen's part wait a minute so coin is the
one who killed all those kids but that
means other people know right
she found rebels who willingly launch
bombs on children how would you keep
that secret oh my dear Miss Everdeen I
thought we'd agreed never to lie to each
other and the honor of this insane
dictatorial murderer holds fast for some
reason as if he has any reason to ever
keep or make a promise to Katniss but it
is narrative ly convenient for the
climax is that you I don't know if
someone asks you if you help murder a
bunch of children and you respond with I
don't know you might as well say yes I
did you want to have another Hunger
Games with the Capitals children you're
joking not in the slightest
with all the hot heads in that room that
RV Emilia opposed to a Hunger Games for
obvious reasons no one decides to kill
Coyne right now Haymitch is the only
person at the table who understands what
Katniss is trying to do
ah the old diegetic sound switcheroo
also they sure lucked up account that
their large arsenal timpani didn't get
destroyed the first movie had the
characters travel down this route and
chariots so who knows how long walking
would take I bet they got out like 15
minutes here so Effie made it our life
obviously look what happened to Caesar
Flickerman does he still get to host his
little show or did the rebels exploded
luckily this execution is stage so that
snow is right in front of Coyne and
Katniss can shoot her arrow without
dramatically changing directions I get
that the rebels all hate snow and wanted
dead but why did none of them go for
Katniss who should be considered a
traitor for killing a new president
Halloween isn't much of a bleeder this
area is probably clean enough for
another execution promise me you'll find
it find what the life of a factor
there's no way she could know what it is
I mean do we really need to find more
ways to fill time and what is
essentially a four and a half hour movie
that only needed to be two hours long is
that the same cat from before the one
that we last saw in the bunker I smell a
spinoff Hunger Games homeward bound part
one holy this is the calmest cat in the
face of flying objects and screaming I
have ever seen we decided to take the
Return of the King route when it comes
to ending the series I found the UH by
the edge of the forest
it's Primrose I'm done you'll be happy
to hear that canada's mother has been
churning new medical units in the
capital this is the second letter being
read to Katniss in five minutes Katniss
is only here to listen to people
describe things not actually what is it
you love me really yeah all Katniss had
to do was the distrust out of Peeta no
happy ending is complete without a baby
thrown into the mix she and Peeta lived
through a horrific war and are no doubt
scarred for life their parents now so
yeah I guess it's a page from the Harry
Potter book of oh god how do I in this
if nightmares - I have nightmares three
one of mine is this movie won't end
your bra bomb better work nerdling err
hey gentlemen
- evil beta release it
so we can't go anywhere in the streets
and the rooftops are just as bad we will
go through the mines stay alive stay
alive no matter what occurs
I will find you I need you to lie back
you're okay yeah I gonna be okay say the
goddamn words you're gonna be okay
Jenny Forrest
I do love you sorry ma'am can't let you
pass